Hey everybody, you're listening to Smartless, hosted by Jason Bateman, Will Arnett, and myself, Sean Hayes. I know, I wish my voice was more masculine too. This show is about learning through laughter and the brains of people around the world who are far smarter than us three idiots. And each week, one of us brings on a guest who the other two don't know about. So with that, let's jump into the Smartless rocket ship and let's blast off into the universe together. Ooh, I think I just turned myself on.
大家好，你们正在收听的是《Smartless》，由杰森·贝特曼、威尔·阿奈特和我，肖恩·海耶斯共同主持。我知道，我也希望我的声音能更阳刚一点。这个节目旨在通过欢笑和世界各地比我们这三个笨蛋聪明得多的人的大脑来学习。每周，我们中的一个人会请来一位另外两人都不知道的嘉宾。那么，让我们跳上“Smartless”火箭飞船，一起冲向宇宙吧。噢，我想我刚才把自己给撩到了。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. I went to seventh grade with Janet Jackson. Are you serious?
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. 我和珍妮·杰克逊是七年级的同学。你是认真的吗？
Did you? Yeah, at a school called Valley Professional. Hold on, it was a school that was only from 9 a.m. to 12 p.m. so that you had your afternoons free for auditioning. For auditions, yeah. It was sort of like the back of a gas station on Sherman Way and Vineland,
真的吗？是的，在一所叫“山谷专业学校”的地方。等等，那所学校每天只有上午9点到中午12点上课，这样你们下午就有空去试镜了。为了试镜，没错。它就像是谢尔曼大道和文兰大道交汇处的一个加油站后面，
and I'm not sure they were accredited. I think chances are high that they were not accredited. I went to high school with one of the kids, this is not a bit, from the original Degrassi Junior High. I went to college with, I was piano majors with Craig Robinson from the office really oh Yeah, I knew that wait. I knew that piano majors together. Yeah, what's a piano major? You major in piano and you don't minor in it get it major. Oh, there are different ranks
而且我不确定他们是否有办学资质。我觉得他们很有可能没有资质。我和原版《迪格拉西初中》里的一个孩子上过高中，这不是段子。我和《办公室》里的克雷格·罗宾逊是大学同学，我们都是钢琴专业的。真的吗？噢，是的，我知道那个。等等，我知道那个。我们一起学的钢琴专业。是的，什么是钢琴专业？你主修钢琴，而且不能把它当辅修，明白吗，是主修。噢，还有不同的等级呢。
there's different because I was a piano Colonel, but and then That is so dumb. I can't believe you you it's a stupid course you're gonna laugh I just watched you haze cuz I knew I knew that would get so down anyway at ease Who's our guest whose guest is it today whose guest is it today guys today my guest today grew up in the Bronx He became interested in astronomy at the age of nine after visiting the Hayden Planetarium and today. Is this Derek Cheater? No, it's not Derek Cheater, close.
有不同的等级，因为我曾是钢琴上校，但是……那太蠢了。我真不敢相信你……这是一个愚蠢的课程，你会笑的。我刚才看着你，肖恩，因为我知道那会让你……总之，稍息。今天的嘉宾是谁？今天的嘉宾是谁，伙计们？今天，我的嘉宾是在布朗克斯长大的。他在参观海登天文馆后，9岁时就对天文学产生了兴趣。今天……这是德里克·基特吗？不，不是德里克·基特，很接近了。
He's now the director of that same planetarium. And after studying at Harvard, he earned his doctorate from Columbia University. He was awarded the NASA Distinguished Public Service Medal. Sean, you've really done it this time. He's known for his ability to make difficult concepts accessible to every audience will sure Yeah, so guys we have with us today my favorite astrophysicist of all infinity Neil deGrasse Tyson Unbelievable Sean
他现在是同一家天文馆的馆长。在哈佛学习后，他在哥伦比亚大学获得了博士学位。他被授予了NASA杰出公共服务奖章。肖恩，你这次真的做到了。他以能让各种听众都能理解高深概念而闻名。威尔，当然。是的，所以伙计们，今天我们请到了我最喜欢的无限宇宙天体物理学家，尼尔·德格拉塞·泰森。不可思议，肖恩。
Yeah, hey guys what an honor. Thank you so much for being on here. I know this is Very nice of you to come and chat with us today I want to you know for being on here. I know this is very nice of you to come and chat with us today. I wanna, you know, do people kind of like jump right in and ask you things about the universe in the same way one might, you know, after discovering someone's a doctor and go, you know, I have a pain in my lower back. Without hesitation. Yeah, instead of asking you about you first.
是的，嘿，伙计们，真是荣幸。非常感谢你能来这里。我知道这……你能来和我们聊天真是太好了。我想，你知道……人们是不是会直接跳过寒暄，问你关于宇宙的问题，就像有些人发现某人是医生后，会说：“你知道吗，我下背部有点疼。”毫不犹豫地。是的，而不是先问问你本人。
Yeah, no, I don't care about me. And as an educator, I don't think who I teach should care about me. That's like cult building. Really? Yeah, so compare these two scenarios. Someone comes up to me and say, hey, aren't you Neil deGrasse? I said yes. Tell me more about a black hole in this.
是的，不，我不在乎我自己。作为一名教育者，我不认为我教的人应该关心我。那就像是在搞个人崇拜。真的吗？是的，所以比较一下这两种情况。有人走过来对我说：“嘿，你不是尼尔·德格拉塞吗？”我说：“是的。”“告诉我更多关于黑洞的事。”
So that's the perfect educational encounter. The one that's not is, are you Neil Tyson? I said yes. Oh, what's your favorite color? What's your favorite? And all of a sudden, I become the object of their curiosity rather than the universe itself. And in that way, I have failed.
所以那是一次完美的教育邂逅。而不完美的是：“你是尼尔·泰森吗？”我说：“是的。”“你最喜欢的颜色是什么？你最喜欢的……”突然之间，我成了他们好奇的对象，而不是宇宙本身。从这个角度来看，我失败了。
And you don't like that? No, it's a failure. No, no, it's a failure of my educational efforts if I become the object of their interest. That's all. I'll do it and I'll accommodate it. But on a certain level, you feel like you failed in your objective. Must not have made the science interesting enough for them to come at that but not knowing you I would think
你不喜欢那样？不，那是一种失败。不，不，如果我成了他们兴趣的对象，那是我教育工作的失败。就是这样。我会配合，我会满足他们。但在某种程度上，你会觉得你没能实现目标。一定是因为没能让科学变得足够有趣，让他们产生那种好奇，但如果不认识你，我会觉得……
You know all why all I ever see of you and again I'm such a huge fan of yours, and I could hear you talk about all of this Crap which I love for hours. Oh, but the stuff that he spent his life studying you you summed up as crap Thank you Sean This is why I don't have a PhD crap is piled high and deep That's what the PhD know but you know what I'm saying Like I like I want to get into that and believe me you will answer all of my questions. I'm here for you Yes
你知道，我所看到的关于你的一切——再说一次，我是你的超级粉丝——我可以听你讲这些“垃圾”讲几个小时，我非常喜欢。噢，但他花了一辈子研究的东西，你总结为“垃圾”。谢谢你，肖恩。这就是我为什么没有博士学位。“垃圾”堆得又高又深，这就是博士学位……不，但你知道我的意思。就像，我想深入了解，相信我，你会回答我所有的问题。我为你而来。是的。
But like when I read that thing that you first became enamored with the universe at nine years old Going to the Hayden planetarium and now years old, going to the Hayden Planetarium, and now you're the director of the Hayden Planetarium, like most teenagers don't have that drive, because I read that you obsessively studied astronomy when you were a teenager. And so most teenagers don't have that drive. What was the thing that kept you going?
但是，当我读到你9岁时第一次迷上宇宙，去海登天文馆，而现在你是海登天文馆的馆长时，大多数青少年都没有那种动力，因为我读到你十几岁时痴迷地研究天文学。所以大多数青少年没有那种动力。是什么让你坚持下去的？
It was like, oh my God, the thirst for knowledge. It wasn't so much the thirst for knowledge, but the fact that I knew that when I looked like, oh my God, the thirst for knowledge. It was the, it wasn't so much the thirst for knowledge, but the fact that I knew that when I looked up, I was completely steeped in ignorance. Boundless ignorance. And so there's this quest. Jason usually just looks in the mirror and that happens. He's so connected with that thought.
那就像是，天哪，对知识的渴望。与其说是对知识的渴望，不如说是因为我知道，当我抬头看时，我完全沉浸在无知之中。无边无际的无知。所以这是一种探索。杰森通常只是照照镜子，那种感觉就来了。他与那个想法联系得太紧密了。
I actually sleep with my eyes open. The fact that there's something around us that we know about which we know so little became this infinite source of curiosity for me. And I've never been the same since, since age nine. And I didn't know that most people are still sort of ambling in college. What am I going to major in? Oh, you major in astronomy. Was that because it's early in the alphabet?
我其实是睁着眼睛睡觉的。我们周围存在着我们知之甚少的事物，这一事实成了我无限好奇心的源泉。从9岁起，我就再也没变过。我不知道大多数人还在大学里晃荡。“我该主修什么？”“噢，你主修天文学。”那是按字母顺序排得比较靠前吗？
You know, no, my stuff goes deep with regard to that. And to that point, explain to people like us idiots who don't know what the difference between astrophysics and astronomy is. Well, so we're all in modern times do astrophysics. Astronomy is the traditional older name for it. But in the late 1800s, we figured out how to apply the laws of physics to what was going on in the universe and thus was birthed
你知道，不，在这方面我的研究很深。说到这一点，给像我们这种不知道天体物理学和天文学区别的笨蛋解释一下吧。嗯，我们现在都做天体物理学。天文学是它传统上较旧的名称。但在19世纪末，我们弄清楚了如何将物理定律应用于宇宙中发生的事情，于是诞生了……
astrophysics. Before then, it's like, well, the star is over here and it's this bright and it's that color. Oh, it might be moving. Okay, so let's call it a planet or it's got a tail. So we call it a comet. So it a cum. It's descriptive. In the 19th century, we learned how to take spectra of stars, and a spectra breaks the light into its colors
天体物理学。在那之前，就像是，“那颗恒星在那儿，它这么亮，它是那种颜色。”“噢，它可能在移动。”好吧，那我们叫它行星，或者它有尾巴。所以我们叫它彗星。它是描述性的。在19世纪，我们学会了如何获取恒星的光谱，光谱将光分解成各种颜色，
like a rainbow, and when you do that, you learn things like how fast is it moving, how fast is it rotating, what it's made of, how long ago it was born, you can create models of that, and so all of a sudden, the universe becomes our backyard. Yeah, because you know, when I still do this, I mean, on the dumbest level, on the most simplest level, there's places on Earth, and it's wearing thin,
就像彩虹一样，当你这样做时，你会了解到它移动得有多快、旋转得有多快、它是由什么组成的、它诞生于多久以前，你可以建立模型，所以突然之间，宇宙就成了我们的后院。是的，因为你知道，当我仍然这样做时，我的意思是，在最笨的层面上，在最简单的层面上，地球上有些地方——而且这种地方越来越少了——
where the air is cleaner, and you can see more stars, somewhere like Hawaii or whatever, and you lie there, and you, like a kid, I still act like a kid, and I look up, and the longer you look up at a clear sky to all the stars, you can't help but think about everything you're talking about, which is where do we come from, that light that we're seeing is way older
空气更清新，你可以看到更多的星星，比如夏威夷什么的，你躺在那里，像个孩子一样——我仍然像个孩子——我抬头看，你盯着晴朗的夜空看的时间越长，你就越忍不住去想你所谈论的一切，那就是我们从哪里来，我们看到的那些光比地球……
than the earth and whatever. That's the one that got me, when I was about 12 years old, the teacher said to me, he said, look up, he said, you see that star? I don't know what I was doing with the teacher in the middle of the night, but he said, the light that you're seeing that's the next that's another episode yeah different episodes a whole different podcast that one's called you
比地球什么的古老得多。那是我12岁时触动我的地方，老师对我说，他说：“抬头看，你看到那颗星了吗？”我不知道半夜我和老师在干什么，但他说了，“你看到的那些光……”那是下一集，是的，不同的剧集，完全不同的播客，那一集叫……
don't want to know then on a very special you don't want to know so he said the light you're seeing right now left that star back in the Roman Empire and I said well what does what does that mean? He says, well, the speed of light is, and correct me if I'm wrong, you're 186,000 miles a second. You got it. So 186,000 miles a second. You just pulled that out?
“你不想知道”。然后在特别节目里，“你不想知道”。所以他说，你现在看到的光是在罗马帝国时期离开那颗恒星的。我说：“那是什么意思？”他说：“嗯，光速是——如果我说错了请纠正我——每秒18.6万英里。”你说对了。所以每秒18.6万英里。你刚才随口就说出来了？
Yeah. I mean, he left a mark. Hold your jokes. Hold your jokes, Will. So if you travel at 186,000 miles a second for a year, that's a light year. So it's a measurement of distance. So he said, so the light traveling at 186,000 miles
是的。我的意思是，他留下了深刻印象。别开玩笑了，威尔。所以如果你以每秒18.6万英里的速度旅行一年，那就是一光年。所以这是一个距离的度量。所以他说，光以每秒18.6万英里的速度……
per second since the Roman Empire, that's how far away that... That light has only just now reached us, that's correct. Yeah, and he said, for instance, the sun, the heat that you're feeling on your face, this is after we woke up, he said, he said, he said, he said that's. And you put down the cigarette.
自罗马帝国以来，那就是那颗星的距离……那些光直到现在才到达我们这里，没错。是的，他说，例如太阳，你脸上感受到的热量——这是在我们醒来之后——他说，他说，他说，那是……你把烟头掐灭了。
Yeah, he put it out on my forearm and he said, that is seven minutes old, the heat from the sun. So that's how far the sun is away. And so- I don't know how you got the speed of light correct and that number wrong. Oh, uh-oh. No, but you're close enough.
是的，他在我的前臂上掐灭了烟头，他说，太阳的热量是7分钟前的。所以太阳离我们有那么远。所以……我不知道你是怎么把光速记对，却把那个数字记错的。噢，噢。不，但你已经很接近了。
No, you're close enough. It was a long night, his head. So it's not seven minutes away. I'm gonna give you the correct number. I mean, to know the speed of light to that precision and then get that other number wrong, that's a little weird. But it's eight minutes and 20 seconds, 500 seconds.
不，你已经很接近了。那是一个漫长的夜晚，他的头。所以它不是7分钟的距离。我要给你一个正确的数字。我的意思是，能把光速记得那么精确，却把另一个数字记错，这有点奇怪。但那是8分20秒，500秒。
Wow, that's so close. And by the way, it's not only the light that takes eight minutes and 20 seconds to reach us, so too does it take the sun's gravity. So if you are some giant and plucked the sun out of the middle of the solar system, we would still orbit, we would still feel its gravity. We would not know any different for eight minutes and 20 seconds, and at that instant, we would plunge into darkness
哇，那太接近了。顺便说一句，不仅光需要8分20秒才能到达我们这里，太阳的引力也需要这么久。所以如果你是一个巨人，把太阳从太阳系中心拔出来，我们仍然会绕轨道运行，我们仍然会感受到它的引力。在8分20秒内我们不会察觉到任何不同，在那一瞬间，我们将陷入黑暗，
and fling out into interstellar space. So that is, those moments, those things, a teacher telling Jason that thing, those are mind-blowing moments, and I've had those mind-blowing moments where I hear these things, which obviously, because of what you do throughout your life you must have had a million mind-blowing revelations and stats and things thrown at you and discoveries that you've made. Have you
并被甩入星际空间。所以，那些时刻，那些事情，老师告诉杰森的那件事，那些都是令人震撼的时刻。我也有过那些令人震撼的时刻，我听到了这些事情，显然，因为你一生所做的工作，你一定经历过一百万次令人震撼的启示、数据、被抛向你的发现以及你所做的发现。你是否……
reached the point where it doesn't blow your mind anymore or what are the things that blow your mind about about the universe around us? So everyone I think should have their mind blown at least once a week. That's the mind blowing quota I think should be about that. And if your mind is blowing it means you're not reading enough or you're not exploring enough because there's stuff out there. I'll give you, here's a simple one, ready? If you go to the flower of an apple orchard and count how many petals are on that flower.
达到了那种不再感到震撼的地步，或者说，关于我们周围的宇宙，还有什么事情会让你感到震撼？我认为每个人都应该每周至少有一次感到震撼。我认为震撼的配额应该大约是这样。如果你的大脑没有感到震撼，那意味着你读得不够多，或者探索得不够多，因为外面有很多东西。我给你举个简单的例子，准备好了吗？如果你去苹果园的一朵花那里，数数那朵花上有多少花瓣。
Okay? There are five petals. Then that flower shrivels up and then it becomes the fruit of the tree, the apple. If you cut the apple horizontally through it and you see the chambers, there are five chambers. So there's a correspondence between the number of seed chambers in the apple and the petals on the flower that became the apple I mean, this is just kind of if you don't notice that start noticing it and then there places where and that's not even anything That's got nothing to do with the origin of the universe, but it's something simple. That's around you I've had a question that I've been waiting to talk with somebody like you to help me try to answer.
好吗？有五片花瓣。然后那朵花枯萎了，变成了树上的果实，苹果。如果你把苹果横着切开，看到里面的腔室，有五个腔室。所以苹果里的种子腔室数量和变成苹果的花瓣数量之间存在对应关系。我的意思是，这只是……如果你没注意到，开始注意它吧，然后有些地方……那甚至不算什么，那和宇宙起源毫无关系，但它是一些简单的东西。就在你周围。我有一个问题，我一直等着和像你这样的人谈谈，帮我试着回答。
And it takes a cream, right? You're looking for a cream or an ointment? Or an ointment or a gel. Okay, so if you look with a strong enough telescope, you can see further and further back in time, right? Because you're seeing light that is older or new. Well, you'll contextualize that for me. But basically, you could effectively look at the Big Bang. Yeah, the origin of the universe. Exactly. So you are looking at the past, and then.
你需要一种乳霜，对吧？你在找乳霜还是药膏？或者药膏或凝胶。好吧，如果你用足够强大的望远镜观察，你可以看到越来越久远的过去，对吧？因为你看到的是更古老的光。嗯，你会为我把这个概念化。但基本上，你可以有效地看到大爆炸。是的，宇宙的起源。没错。所以你是在看过去，然后……
By the way, just to be clear. Yeah. We're in a Coronaverse right now, but if I was sitting across the table from you, you don't see me in your present. You see me in your past. Light at 186,000 miles per second goes one foot per nanosecond, one foot per billionth of a second.
顺便说一句，澄清一下。是的。我们现在处于“新冠宇宙”中，但如果我坐在你对面，你看到的不是现在的我。你看到的是过去的我。光以每秒18.6万英里的速度，每纳秒走一英尺，每十亿分之一秒走一英尺。
So if we're like three feet across from each other, you see me not as I am, but as I once was three billionths of a second ago. We don't make a big deal of that because human lifespan is much longer than billionths of a second. But if I start getting farther and farther, the moon is one and a half light seconds, the sun 500 light seconds, the nearest star four light years, you keep going farther and farther away, you get to significant timeframes back into the past of the object you're observing. And that's why, that's where cosmology comes in.
所以如果我们相隔三英尺，你看到的我不是现在的我，而是三纳秒前的我。我们不会对此大惊小怪，因为人类的寿命比十亿分之一秒长得多。但如果我离得越来越远，月球是1.5光秒，太阳是500光秒，最近的恒星是4光年，你离得越远，你就能回到你所观察物体的过去，回到重要的时间框架。这就是宇宙学发挥作用的地方。
It's how we decode the record of the universe because it takes light so much damn time to reach us. And Sean, you were going to take cosmology, right, at one point, just as part of- Yeah, for my skin. Beauty school. Yeah. That's why I glow. And just as for my skin. Beauty school. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
这是我们解码宇宙记录的方式，因为光到达我们需要太长的时间了。肖恩，你曾经打算学习宇宙学，对吧，作为……是的，为了我的皮肤。美容学校。是的。这就是我发光的原因。仅仅是为了我的皮肤。美容学校。是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. That's why I glow. That's why I glow like a star. Beautifully, yes. So if you're looking back at something that happened a long time ago, i.e. the Big Bang,
是的。是的。这就是我发光的原因。这就是我像星星一样发光的原因。很美，是的。所以如果你在回顾很久以前发生的事情，即大爆炸，
somewhere in that Big Bang is our planet, is the Earth. And therefore, you see the Earth before anything has ever happened on it. No. So if you can see back. I'll let you continue, but I should really stop you there, but I'll let you continue. Well, so let's make an assumption
大爆炸的某个地方就是我们的星球，就是地球。因此，你看到了在任何事情发生之前的地球。不。所以如果你能看到过去。我会让你继续，但我真的应该在那里打断你，但我会让你继续。嗯，所以让我们做一个假设，
that the Big Bang was the start of everything, so at some point whatever we're rolling around on here on this rock was in there. So my point is, if you can see all the way back that far is there a a theory Because it would be impossible to actually construct where you could set up a series of Mirrors where you could look back and forth and back and forth and back and forth enough times Theoretically where you could see yesterday yes if you If we can already see the Big Bang,
大爆炸是万物的开端，所以在某个时刻，我们在这块岩石上滚来滚去的东西都在里面。所以我的观点是，如果你能看到那么远，有没有一种理论……因为实际上建立一个你可以设置一系列镜子的地方是不可能的，在那里你可以来回看，来回看，来回看足够多次，理论上你可以看到昨天。是的，如果你……如果我们已经能看到大爆炸，
that's gotta be harder than seeing yesterday, but if you constricted that into, or contracted that rather, into a series of mirrors, then maybe you could eventually see last week, last month. Yeah, so if you put a mirror one light day away from you, and you look at it, you will see yourself yesterday. Right. Okay, but that requires a mirror. The Big Bang is not a mirror.
那一定比看到昨天更难，但如果你把它压缩，或者说收缩成一系列镜子，那么也许你最终能看到上周、上个月。是的，所以如果你放一面镜子在离你一光天远的地方，你看着它，你就会看到昨天的自己。对。好吧，但这需要一面镜子。大爆炸不是一面镜子。
So when you see evidence of the Big Bang that far out, you're not seeing us go through the Big Bang. You're seeing another part of the universe go through the Big Bang. If they looked to where we are, they don't see our light from you right now in this podcast. No. see our light from you right now in this podcast, no. They see Earth and our galaxy 14 billion years ago when we were going through the Big Bang. So you have to be that distance away to see that far in the past.
所以当你看到那么远的大爆炸证据时，你看到的不是我们经历大爆炸。你看到的是宇宙的另一部分经历大爆炸。如果他们看向我们所在的地方，他们看不到我们现在在这个播客里的光。不。看不到我们现在在这个播客里的光，不。他们看到的是140亿年前的地球和我们的银河系，当时我们正在经历大爆炸。所以你必须在那个距离之外才能看到那么久远的过去。
So there is no way to construct a window into the past by setting up a series of well-tuned mirrors? Well, if someone else set that up for you, so you can set up a mirror seven light days away, and then you look at it, you'll see yourself two weeks ago, because it's seven days out, seven days back. So in theory, like Jason could apologize to me for certain things that he did.
所以没有办法通过设置一系列精心调整的镜子来构建一个通往过去的窗口？嗯，如果别人为你设置了那个，你可以设置一面离你一光天远的镜子，然后你看着它，你就会看到两周前的自己，因为它是七天远，七天回。所以理论上，杰森可以为他做过的某些事情向我道歉。
In theory. Do you think we could set enough mirrors in a row so that we could look far back enough to see the start of Jason's question? No, top science is still true to try and work out that. I want to go back again, a lot of people don't ask you about you and I'm interested in you as well as all the other stuff and I still want to get to that, but you have two kids, right?
理论上。你认为我们可以排成一排足够的镜子，让我们能回溯到足以看到杰森的问题开始的时候吗？不，顶尖科学仍然在努力研究那个。我想再回去，很多人不问关于你的问题，我对你和你做的其他所有事情一样感兴趣，我仍然想谈谈那个，但你有两个孩子，对吧？
Did they ever follow in your passion or do they have, are they on TikTok and that's it? There was never that expectation or obligation and they had freedom to think what they want, to study what they want, and they're each doing different things right now. But I can tell you that by the time they were 12 or 13 certified scientifically literate.
他们有没有追随你的热情，或者他们有……他们是在玩TikTok，仅此而已吗？从来没有那种期望或义务，他们有自由去思考他们想要的，去学习他们想要的，他们现在每个人都在做不同的事情。但我可以告诉你，到他们12或13岁时，他们已经具备了科学素养。
Oh wow. Oh yeah. You don't have to tell us, but are they in that world of science? No, no, but they're scientifically literate. So the difference is, if you're scientifically literate, it means your brain is wired for inquiry. It's wired for thought. So that at a young age, I'm happy that they were also polite
噢，哇。噢，是的。你不必告诉我们，但他们是在科学领域吗？不，不，但他们具备科学素养。所以区别在于，如果你具备科学素养，意味着你的大脑是为探究而生的。它是为思考而生的。所以在那样的年纪，我很高兴他们也很有礼貌，
when they did this, because otherwise it would be embarrassing, if you were a grown up, walked into the room, and you said something, oh, I checked my horoscope sign today, and my 12-year-old, 13-year-old kids heard that? They would say, well, what did you find? They would start asking questions. And what are you basing that on? And have you tested it? And they just calmly sort of ask the questions
当他们这样做的时候，因为否则会很尴尬，如果你是一个成年人，走进房间，你说了一些话，“噢，我今天查了我的星座运势”，而我12岁、13岁的孩子听到了？他们会说：“嗯，你发现了什么？”他们会开始问问题。“你基于什么？”“你测试过吗？”他们只是冷静地提出问题，
to drive you into the corner that you really are in because you have no foundation for those thoughts. That's the science literacy that I'm talking about that anybody can and should cultivate for themselves, whether or not you become a scientist. Neil, if you could pick one subject that you would have an equal level depth of knowledge about, what would it be?
把你逼进你真正所处的角落，因为你对这些想法没有任何基础。这就是我所说的科学素养，任何人都可以也应该为自己培养，无论你是否成为科学家。尼尔，如果你能选择一个你想要拥有同等深度知识的学科，那会是什么？
Is there another area? Thanks for that question. If I had a, if there's a parallel universe. Uh-oh, here we go. An alternative, not in this universe, but another universe. In another universe, I would be writing songs for Broadway musicals. Wow.
还有其他领域吗？谢谢你的提问。如果我有一个……如果有一个平行宇宙。噢，开始了。一个替代的，不是在这个宇宙，而是另一个宇宙。在另一个宇宙，我会为百老汇音乐剧写歌。哇。
Are you serious? Do you write? Do you play anything? Oh, here comes Sean. No, this is why it's another universe. That's why I said. So I don't have musical ability, but I do, I like to write.
你是认真的吗？你会写吗？你会演奏什么吗？噢，肖恩来了。不，这就是为什么它是另一个宇宙。所以我没有音乐天赋，但我确实，我喜欢写作。
I like knowing the effect that words have on your emotions, on your thoughts, on your enlightenment. I like simplifying phrases. And good songs are not complex stories. Go read a book if you wanted a complex story. It's gonna hit you emotionally. So, my family, we go to musical theater often. I will tear up at a simple Broadway boy meets girl musical
我喜欢了解文字对你的情绪、你的思想、你的启蒙所产生的影响。我喜欢简化短语。好的歌曲不是复杂的故事。如果你想要复杂的故事，去读书吧。它会从情感上击中你。所以，我的家人，我们经常去看音乐剧。我会因为一个简单的百老汇男孩遇见女孩的音乐剧而流泪，
or nowadays it's boy meets boy, girl meets girl. Any of those where there is the expression of human emotion. Well, thank you for checking out the 2010 smash hit on Broadway Promises Promises starring Sean Hayes and Kristin Chenoweth. That's so nice of you. That's incredible.
或者现在是男孩遇见男孩，女孩遇见女孩。任何有表达人类情感的地方。好吧，谢谢你观看2010年百老汇大热剧《Promises Promises》，由肖恩·海耶斯和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯主演。你真是太好了。这太不可思议了。
Way to go backstage, Neil. Yeah. So if I had an alternative universe, so I'd like to write and so when I write my books, each sentence, each phrasing, each turn of the syllables of a word, I'm thinking about how that lands in the reader. And I think if it's done well, that's what it should be like, because then you'll just want more of it. So if there's another universe, that's what it should be like. Because then you'll just want more of it. So if there's another universe,
去后台吧，尼尔。是的。所以如果我有一个替代宇宙，我喜欢写作，所以当我写书时，每一个句子，每一个措辞，每一个音节的转折，我都在思考它如何落在读者身上。我认为如果做得好，就应该是这样，因为那样你就会想要更多。所以如果有一个另一个宇宙，
that's what I'd be doing in that universe. I have an idea and this is, I'm not being snarky here at all. What if you wrote a space musical? Like if you, I could see, that would be really interesting if you somehow, I mean, would anybody think to make a musical about Hamilton? You know, like that's just bizarre. Yeah, the fascinating fact about Broadway musicals
那才是我在那个宇宙会做的事情。我有一个想法，而且这……我一点也不刻薄。如果你写一部太空音乐剧怎么样？就像如果你……我能看到，如果以某种方式……我的意思是，有人会想到为《汉密尔顿》制作音乐剧吗？你知道，那太离奇了。是的，关于百老汇音乐剧的一个迷人事实是，
is that they have been on every possible subject you couldn't ever have imagined. But not space. Hamilton, cats, the prime minister of Argentina. You know, just make the list. How does that even happen? So why don't you do that? Because that's another, didn't I, how did I start this? I said in another universe.
它们涵盖了你无法想象的每一个可能的主题。但不是太空。《汉密尔顿》、《猫》、阿根廷总理。你知道，列个清单吧。那怎么会发生呢？所以你为什么不那样做呢？因为那是另一个……我不是开始了吗？我说在另一个宇宙。
But you could be the creative consultant. You're saying he could write the book and somebody else could write the music. Yeah, I think so. I would need a... I do have some ideas and I have notes in my book. Comic. Call Sean. I got the universe. But we're making deals here. But you know, it's funny that you say, Neil, that you say that there are Broadway musicals
但你可以担任创意顾问。你是说他可以写剧本，别人可以写音乐。是的，我想可以。我需要一个……我确实有一些想法，我的书里有笔记。漫画。给肖恩打电话。我掌握了宇宙。但我们在这里做交易。但你知道，尼尔，你说……你说百老汇音乐剧基于每一个可以想象的主题，这很有趣。
based on every conceivable subject. The president of Argentina with Evita, whatever it is. And that kind of reminded me of, and this whole conversation reminded me of somebody one time explaining to me the idea of infinity. And they said, imagine infinity is, imagine a room, imagine a library that is filled with books on every possible subject,
阿根廷总统，艾薇塔，不管是什么。这让我想起了……整个谈话让我想起了有人曾经向我解释无限的概念。他们说，想象无限是……想象一个房间，想象一个图书馆，里面装满了关于每一个可能主题的书，
including me describing that library to you. There's a book about me describing that book to you. There's on every possible- We go with the mirrors again. The effect of me describing that to you. Oh, we got it. What effect that has on butterflies, like whatever. Understood, moving forward.
包括我向你描述那个图书馆。有一本书是关于我向你描述那本书的。有关于每一个可能的……我们又回到镜子了。我向你描述那个的影响。噢，我们明白了。这对蝴蝶有什么影响，之类的。明白了，继续。
And so then imagine that they're stacked in every direction. Yeah. As far as you can see, they said that's what infinity is. We got it. No, no, no, the libraries themselves. End it with a question. Will, can I talk to you for a sec? My question is this.
然后想象它们在各个方向堆叠。是的。只要你能看到，他们说这就是无限。我们明白了。不，不，不，图书馆本身。用一个问题结束。威尔，我能和你谈谈吗？我的问题是这样的。
I got one for you. I'll give you a starter infinity, right? Because it's not really infinity, but it is something to think about. So, consider that if you open a dictionary, every word used in the definition of every word is in that same dictionary. Yeah. That's kind of mind-blowing. Yeah, that is interesting. I never thought about that. Okay. Now, the other things that are sort of transcend comprehension. Pinocchio. Okay, here's a sentence that Pinocchio utters. Ready?
我有一个问题要问你。我给你一个入门级的无限，好吗？因为它不是真正的无限，但它值得思考。所以，考虑到如果你打开一本字典，定义每个单词所用的每个单词都在同一本字典里。是的。这有点令人震撼。是的，这很有趣。我从来没想过那个。好吧。现在，其他一些超越理解的东西。匹诺曹。好吧，这是匹诺曹说的一句话。准备好了吗？
My nose is about to grow. Pinocchio, okay, here's a sentence that Pinocchio utters. Ready? My nose is about to grow. What will happen? It's gonna grow. It's gonna grow, probably. It's not gonna grow. It's not gonna grow. Pinocchio's a liar.
我的鼻子快要长了。匹诺曹，好吧，这是匹诺曹说的一句话。准备好了吗？我的鼻子快要长了。会发生什么？它会长。它会长，可能。它不会长。它不会长。匹诺曹是个骗子。
Let me finish, it's not gonna grow. That means he was lying. So that's right, so it's not gonna grow. No, that means he was telling the truth. Okay, so let me get to some other questions I have. My point is that sentence has no meaning in Pinocchio's universe, even though the nouns and verbs are all in the right place.
让我说完，它不会长。这意味着他在撒谎。所以那是对的，所以它不会长。不，这意味着他在说实话。好吧，让我谈谈我有的其他问题。我的观点是，那句话在匹诺曹的宇宙中没有意义，即使名词和动词都在正确的位置。
It transcends the world that you have set up to understand Pinocchio's statements and his actions. It's a very simple sentence. Given that we agree upon the rules of Pinocchio. Yes, yes. We all, of course we agree. Of course we agree. Given those rules, this is a sentence
它超越了你为理解匹诺曹的陈述和行为而设定的世界。这是一个非常简单的句子。鉴于我们同意匹诺曹的规则。是的，是的。我们都，当然我们同意。当然我们同意。鉴于那些规则，这是一个句子，
that cannot even be uttered in his world. Okay, so infinity is something that is not fundamentally accessible to the wiring of our brain because our brain evolved on the planes of the Serengeti to not get chased by a lion. Okay, not get eaten by a lion. This is so that the tools we need to not die in our evolutionary past do not include infinity. So based on that, so Neil, so our brains are not wired to understand the concept of, fundamentally to understand the concept of infinity.
甚至不能在他的世界里说出来。好吧，所以无限是我们的大脑结构在根本上无法触及的东西，因为我们的大脑是在塞伦盖蒂平原上进化出来的，为了不被狮子追赶。好吧，不被狮子吃掉。这是为了让我们在进化史上不至于死亡所需的工具不包括无限。所以基于此，所以尼尔，所以我们的大脑不是为了理解这个概念而设计的，从根本上无法理解无限的概念。
Yeah, there's an absence of logic. We are logical creatures relative to other life forms, but our capacity to not be logical knows no bounds. And... But the fact that you know that, and so you have to make certain leaps in order to try to... How do you hack that in order to make discoveries and things that you have to do?
是的，缺乏逻辑。相对于其他生命形式，我们是逻辑生物，但我们不合逻辑的能力是无限的。而且……但你既然知道这一点，所以你必须做出某些飞跃才能尝试……你是如何破解它以做出发现和你必须做的事情的？
What is... Do you know, and are you just aware of your own inability to do it simultaneously? It comes from the math. So you do the math long enough, then you absorb the math as part of your intuition. So you can think intuitively about what the math equations would have done rather than relying solely on how you would have not getting eaten by a lion and the wiring that that provides.
什么是……你知道吗，你是否同时意识到自己无法做到这一点？它来自数学。所以你做数学做得足够久，然后你就把数学吸收为直觉的一部分。所以你可以直观地思考数学方程会做什么，而不是仅仅依赖于你如何不被狮子吃掉以及那所提供的结构。
So you start building up other wiring in your brain that empowers you to think in these other ways. And this is how you think in the quantum. The quantum world is really weird. Particles popping in and out of existence, particles simultaneously existing as a wave, and a wave particle duality, you might have heard of this. All of this is fundamental, and the mathematics describes it, the experiments measure it.
所以你开始在你的大脑中建立其他结构，使你有能力以这些其他方式思考。这就是你在量子领域思考的方式。量子世界真的很奇怪。粒子进出存在，粒子同时作为波存在，波粒二象性，你可能听说过这个。所有这些都是基本的，数学描述它，实验测量它。
The brain cannot comprehend it. I know we don't have a lot of time, I have tons of questions, so let's do like, not a rapid fire. A lightning round, I'm good, I got you. Okay. Let's do it. So how... Foxes are briefs. But... And by the way,
大脑无法理解它。我知道我们没有太多时间，我有很多问题，所以让我们做个……不是快问快答。闪电战，我准备好了，我听着。好的。让我们开始吧。所以如何……狐狸是短裤。但是……顺便说一句，
my lightning answers need to be matched with your lightning questions, just to be clear, in order for that to work. No, we're here to listen to you. If you guys have something to follow, but these are really, I wrote these down because I really want to know. Are we ever going to get to Mars and why do we want to?
我的闪电回答需要与你的闪电问题相匹配，为了清楚起见，为了让它工作。不，我们在这里听你的。如果你们有什么要跟进的，但这些真的……我把它们写下来了，因为我真的很想知道。我们能去火星吗？为什么我们要去？
We will if it has geopolitical priorities, but otherwise I think it's a very distant dream. So if China says they want to put military bases on Mars, we're there in nine months. If not- Come on. Really? Really? Yeah, yeah. We're going to the moon again, is that right? Did I just read that? on Mars, we're there in nine months. If not... Come on. Really? Really. Yeah.
如果我们有地缘政治优先事项，我们就会去，否则我认为这是一个非常遥远的梦想。所以如果中国说他们想在火星上建立军事基地，我们九个月内就会到那里。如果不是……得了吧。真的吗？真的吗？是的，是的。我们又要去月球了，对吧？我刚才读到那个了吗？在火星上，我们九个月内就会到那里。如果不是……得了吧。真的吗？真的。是的。
We're going to the moon again. Is that right? Did I just read that? Yeah, because other countries are gaining power over what's called cislunar space, the space between Earth and the moon, and that's the new high ground. So there are geopolitical forces that make all of that happen. The business cases come later, the tourism, then all the rest of this and the SpaceX, that all comes after. The first forays out there are countries who have geopolitical interest in mind. Columbus came to the new world. Did Queen Isabella say, oh, Columbus, take pictures and bring them back and tell us? No. It was like, here's a satchel of Spanish flags. Plant them wherever you go and find a shorter trade route to India.
我们又要去月球了。对吧？我刚才读到那个了吗？是的，因为其他国家正在获得对所谓“地月空间”的控制权，即地球和月球之间的空间，那是新的制高点。所以有地缘政治力量使这一切发生。商业案例稍后出现，旅游业，然后是其余的一切，还有SpaceX，所有这些都在那之后。第一次出征那里的是那些有地缘政治利益的国家。哥伦布来到新大陆。伊莎贝拉女王说，噢，哥伦布，拍些照片带回来告诉我们吗？不。就像，这里有一袋西班牙国旗。无论你去哪里都插上它们，找到一条去印度的更短贸易路线。
It's always been the driver of humanity. Always, always. So, because I'm obsessed with the speed of light, how soon will we be able to travel the speed of light? Because so many scientists, you know, through the, wait. But wait, they've informed us of certain laws of physics. I'm just wondering when do we start applying those? So breaking the light barrier is not the same thing as breaking the sound barrier. When you heard people say, oh we'll never fly,
它一直是人类的驱动力。一直，一直。所以，因为我痴迷于光速，我们什么时候能以光速旅行？因为这么多科学家，你知道，通过……等等。但等等，他们告诉了我们某些物理定律。我只是想知道我们什么时候开始应用它们？所以打破光障和打破音障是不一样的。当你听到人们说，噢，我们永远不会飞，
and they were just idiots, you know why? Because birds fly, alright, and they're heavier than air, you just haven't figured it out yet. And can you never go faster than sound? Rifle bullets went faster than sound before we had planes. So we can make things faster than sound. Just figure it out. The speed of light is not just a good idea sound, rifle bullets went faster than sound before we had planes. So we can make things faster than sound. Just figure it out. The speed of light is not just a good idea as the law of the universe.
他们只是笨蛋，你知道为什么吗？因为鸟会飞，好吧，它们比空气重，你只是还没弄明白而已。你永远不能比声音快吗？步枪子弹在有飞机之前就比声音快了。所以我们可以制造比声音快的东西。只要弄明白就行。光速不仅仅是一个好主意，它是宇宙的定律。
And if you want to go faster, you have to like tunnel through space time or have warp drives, which is what all the science fiction ones do. They don't just actually travel faster than light. They try to find some plausible scientific accounting for how they can travel faster than light. And I applaud them all for that. Right, so why then, after what seems like a hundred years, is the only means of fast travel in airplane? Because doesn't it seem like by now there should be some kind of improvement on the plane? The only improvement is, you know, the seat...
如果你想走得更快，你必须像穿过时空隧道或拥有曲速驱动器，这就是所有科幻小说所做的。他们不仅仅是实际上比光走得快。他们试图找到一些合理的科学解释，说明他们如何能比光走得快。我为他们所有人鼓掌。对，那么为什么，在似乎一百年后，快速旅行的唯一方式是飞机？因为难道不觉得现在应该对飞机进行某种改进吗？唯一的改进是，你知道，座位……
Sean, don't get pissed off. I know, he sounds angry. No, I am. He's not angry today. I am because I'm frustrated that... This is the lightning round, right? I'm going to tell you. Oh, sorry, go ahead.
肖恩，别生气。我知道，他听起来很生气。不，我是。他今天不生气。我是，因为我很沮丧……这是闪电战，对吧？我要告诉你。噢，抱歉，请继续。
Here it is. Now somebody else is angry. Some of you are old enough to remember the Concorde SST. Supersonic, right? Yeah, sure. Okay. So that's like the next leap from an ordinary airplane. Do you know something?
在这里。现在别人也生气了。你们中有些人年纪够大，还记得协和式超音速客机。超音速，对吧？是的，当然。好吧。所以那是继普通飞机之后的下一次飞跃。你知道吗？
We didn't have a supersonic commercial plane, but France and England did. That was the Concorde. And I always wondered why they stopped making them. Oh, you know why? Oh, well, wait a minute. Why can't they fly to Los Angeles? Oh, we're not going to let them because they'll have a sonic boom over the continental United States.
我们没有超音速商用飞机，但法国和英国有。那是协和式飞机。我一直想知道为什么他们停止制造它们。噢，你知道为什么吗？噢，好吧，等一下。为什么它们不能飞往洛杉矶？噢，我们不会让它们飞，因为它们会在美国大陆上空产生音爆。
So we cut them off at their kneecaps and said, yeah, you can fly, but you can only cross the ocean. That greatly limited the growth of that supersonic industry. And why don't we want a sonic boom over the country? Because it's too scary? What? It can shatter dishes and things and knock them off. The space shuttle did it, though.
所以我们切断了它们的膝盖，说，是的，你可以飞，但你只能跨越海洋。这极大地限制了超音速工业的发展。为什么我们不想要国内上空的音爆？因为太吓人了吗？什么？它会震碎盘子之类的东西，把它们震掉。航天飞机做到了，虽然。
Well, that's because it's coming in over Florida, and it's over a low density area and mostly ocean. So you have to understand, Neal, Sean's theory is that if you're high enough, anything's okay. It's so stupid. So what we really want is hypersonic transportation where you get to Tokyo in an hour and a half. This would be suborbital. I want that. Right. Okay, that's even faster than just the Concorde. You know if you go suborbital, you are not farther than 45 minutes from any two places anywhere on earth. Here's the problem.
嗯，那是因为它是在佛罗里达上空进入的，而且是在低密度地区和大部分海洋上空。所以你必须明白，尼尔，肖恩的理论是，如果你足够高，什么都行。这太蠢了。所以我们真正想要的是高超音速运输，让你在一个半小时内到达东京。这将是亚轨道的。我想要那个。对。好吧，那甚至比协和式飞机还要快。你知道如果你进行亚轨道飞行，你距离地球上任何两个地方都不超过45分钟。问题在这里。
What does it mean that it took you an hour and a half to drive to the airport and another 45 minutes in TSA? So it took you three hours, and then you got to park the car, three hours to take a 45-minute trip to Tokyo. There's a point where, just put me on an airplane where I have internet and hours, and then you gotta park the car, three hours to take a 45 minute trip to Tokyo. There's a point where, just put me on an airplane where I have internet and movies and I'm fine, and I don't need to get there faster. So correct me if I'm wrong, this is what suborbital is.
开车去机场花了一个半小时，在TSA又花了45分钟，这意味着什么？所以花了三个小时，然后你还得停车，三个小时去东京进行45分钟的旅行。有一个点，只要把我放在一架有互联网和电影的飞机上，我就很好，我不需要更快到达那里。所以如果我说错了请纠正我，这就是亚轨道飞行吗？
The Earth is rotating at 1,000 miles an hour, right? At the equator, at the equator. So it's spinning around, let's say, 1,000 miles an hour. A plane really, let's for interest in math or easy numbers, it goes 500 say, 1,000 miles an hour. A plane really, let's for interest in math or easy numbers, it goes 500 miles an hour. 500 miles an hour. Right, so if you're going the direction the Earth is rotating, you're never going to get
地球以每小时1000英里的速度自转，对吧？在赤道，是在赤道。所以它在旋转，假设是每小时1000英里。一架飞机，为了数学上的趣味或方便计算，假设它以每小时500英里，每小时500英里的速度飞行。对吧，所以如果你朝着地球自转的方向飞行，你永远也无法到达那个目的地。
to that destination. No, because you're. Because you're inside this three mile gravitational bubble, right? Neil, you should know that the teacher told him that on the second night. Because he stayed for a second night. We had a wonderful time, wonderful time.
不，因为你……因为你在一个三英里厚的引力气泡里，对吧？尼尔，你应该知道，老师在第二天晚上告诉过他。因为他多住了一晚。我们度过了一段美好的时光，非常美好的时光。
No, no, so if you launch your plane at the equator and you stay in Earth's atmosphere, because it's flying through the Earth's atmosphere, Earth is turning at 1,000 miles an hour, the air is moving at 1,000 miles an hour, the plane is moving at 1,000 miles an hour, now it goes 500 miles an hour, so it's going 1,500 miles an hour through space.
不，不，如果你在赤道发射飞机，并且你停留在地球大气层内，因为它是在地球大气层中飞行，地球以每小时1000英里的速度转动，空气以每小时1000英里的速度移动，飞机以每小时1000英里的速度移动，现在它以每小时500英里的速度飞行，所以它在太空中是以每小时1500英里的速度前进。
But if you go straight up and you leave this three mile sort of bubble, you then leave gravitational pull and you can take advantage of that 1,000 mile an hour spin. They want that 1,000 miles to get a little extra boost to go into orbit around the earth. And orbital speed is 18,000 miles an hour. So you get a little boost by doing that. If you go back the opposite way, you gotta make up 2,000 miles an hour. So you get a little boost by doing that.
但如果你径直向上飞，离开了这个三英里左右的气泡，你就离开了引力牵引，你可以利用那每小时1000英里的自转速度。他们想要那1000英里的速度来获得额外的推力，以便进入地球轨道。而轨道速度是每小时18000英里。所以这样做可以获得一点推力。如果你往相反方向飞，你就得补足每小时2000英里的速度。所以这样做可以获得一点推力。
If you go back the opposite way, you gotta make up 2,000 miles per hour's worth of speed. And if you can do that. But even if you just went straight up like a rocket does, and you leave that. No, it doesn't. In fact, they don't do that. I'm saying if, but if you. No, just be clear, some people don't know.
如果你往相反方向飞，你就得补足每小时2000英里的速度。如果你能做到的话。但即使你像火箭那样径直向上飞，你离开了……不，它不是那样。事实上，他们不那样做。我是说如果，但如果你……不，说清楚点，有些人不知道。
Most of the energy of a rocket launch is not to go up. It is to go downstream and give it enough sideways speed so that it doesn't fall out of the sky. Wow. So the space shuttle, the space station, they're all going 18,000 miles an hour sideways. That's why Mission Control, you now go through the Execute the Roll program. And this is the space shuttle now going sideways downstream. We're down. So that's so they're not going up.
火箭发射的大部分能量不是为了向上飞。而是为了向侧面飞，给它足够的横向速度，这样它就不会从天上掉下来。哇。所以航天飞机、空间站，它们都在以每小时18000英里的速度横向飞行。这就是为什么任务控制中心会说，现在执行翻滚程序。这就是航天飞机现在横向飞行。我们下来了。所以它们不是在向上飞。
They're going sideways. That's most of their energy. We think space is up. You know how high up they go. But where do you guys live? Where you live? In LA? OK, they are less above Earth's surface than the distance of San Francisco from Los Angeles. Okay? In fact, they're half that distance. How many miles San Francisco? It's like four?
它们在横向飞行。那是它们大部分的能量。我们以为太空是在上面。你知道它们飞得有多高吗？但你们住在哪里？你们住哪？洛杉矶？好吧，它们距离地球表面的高度比旧金山到洛杉矶的距离还要近。好吧？事实上，只有那个距离的一半。旧金山有多少英里？大概四百？
300 miles, 350 miles? Yeah, it's about three, yeah. Yeah, about 350 miles. So two thirds of that, that's the height that the space shuttle flies. So you can drive that in a few hours. That's not even what the rocket is doing, okay? It's just getting up above the atmosphere
300英里，350英里？是的，大概三百，是的。是的，大概350英里。所以那个高度的三分之二，就是航天飞机飞行的高度。所以你开车几个小时就能到。那甚至不是火箭在做的事情，好吗？它只是为了飞到大气层之上，
because it doesn't have to plow through air. By the way, if we didn't have an atmosphere, it would just go sideways. Just launch it sideways, okay? So once you're above the atmosphere, you're outside the gravitational pull, right? How tall is the atmosphere? No, the last we checked,
因为它不需要穿过空气。顺便说一句，如果我们没有大气层，它就会直接横向飞行。直接横向发射它，好吗？所以一旦你到了大气层之上，你就离开了引力牵引，对吧？大气层有多高？不，我们最后一次检查时，
Earth is orbited by the moon. The moon feels Earth's gravity. So Moon. The Moon feels Earth's gravity. So all astronauts are deep within Earth's gravity. The difference is they're weightless, not because they've left Earth's gravity, but because they are falling towards Earth. So here's the brilliance of Isaac Newton. You want something mind-blowing? Here it is.
月球绕着地球运行。月球感受到了地球的引力。所以月球。月球感受到了地球的引力。所以所有的宇航员都深处地球的引力之中。区别在于他们处于失重状态，不是因为他们离开了地球的引力，而是因为他们正在向地球坠落。这就是艾萨克·牛顿的才华所在。想要点令人大开眼界的东西吗？就是这个。
Isaac Newton. He said, hmm, there's the Moon in orbit around the earth and I drop an apple and it falls straight to earth. Is this the same thing or is it two different things going on? And then he had a thought experiment. This is why he's Isaac Newton and we're the rest of us. He said, suppose I have a mountain and I have a cannon and I fire a cannonball from that mountain horizontally.
艾萨克·牛顿。他说，嗯，月球在绕着地球运行，我扔下一个苹果，它径直落向地球。这是同一回事，还是两件不同的事情？然后他做了一个思想实验。这就是为什么他是艾萨克·牛顿，而我们是其他人。他说，假设我有一座山，我有一门大炮，我从那座山上水平发射一颗炮弹。
It'll go out a few hundred yards and hit the ground, right? Suppose I fire it faster. It'll go farther along earth's yards and hit the ground, right? Suppose I fire it faster. It'll go farther along Earth's surface before it hits the ground. Let me keep increasing the speed, and it falls farther and farther away from you. There must be a speed where it falls so far away from you, it completely goes around the Earth and hits you in the back of the head. Well, at that point, just duck, and the ball continues in what we call orbit. And that entire time, it was falling towards Earth.
它会飞出几百码然后撞到地面，对吧？假设我发射得更快。它会在撞击地面之前沿着地球表面飞得更远。让我不断增加速度，它落下的地方离你越来越远。一定有一个速度，让它落下的地方离你那么远，以至于它完全绕地球一圈，然后砸中你的后脑勺。好吧，在那一点上，只要蹲下，球就会继续我们所说的轨道运行。而在那整个过程中，它都在向地球坠落。
The difference is, it fell by the exact amount that Earth curved away from it. I try to throw knowledge at Jason from a low distance, and it never hits him in the head. Never, ever hits him in the head. No, just think about this. This is profound. Think about this.
区别在于，它下落的距离正好等于地球表面弯曲远离它的距离。我试着从低处向杰森扔知识，但它从来没砸中过他的头。从来没有，从来没砸中过他的头。不，想想这个。这很深刻。想想这个。
You're going sideways so fast that when you've dropped a foot, when you've dropped a foot, Earth's curvature curves away from you by a foot. So you never catch up to it. You never catch up to the Earth. Thus is the definition of an orbit and you're in free fall the entire time,
你横向飞行的速度如此之快，以至于当你下落一英尺时，地球的曲率也弯曲远离你一英尺。所以你永远追不上它。你永远追不上地球。这就是轨道的定义，而且你整个过程都处于自由落体状态，
like cutting the cables of an elevator, falling straight down, except you happen to have sideways motion. And so falling straight down means you never hit the Earth. Neil, there's a lot of debate about this, because I know you gotta go, but there's a lot of debate about, do you agree, a lot of people say
就像切断了电梯的缆绳，径直下落，只不过你恰好有横向运动。所以径直下落意味着你永远不会撞到地球。尼尔，关于这一点有很多争论，因为我知道你得走了，但关于这一点有很多争论，你同意吗，很多人说
that the best season of Will & Grace was season five. Do you think that that's true? Because. Okay, wait, I know you have to go, but I really, this is the biggest one I wanted to talk to you about, and we can just plow right through it. What's that?
《威尔和格蕾丝》最好的一季是第五季。你觉得那是真的吗？因为。好吧，等等，我知道你得走了，但我真的，这是我最想和你讨论的一件事，我们可以直接把它讲完。是什么？
I wanna talk about aliens, I love them, I wanna meet them, if I can. Nobody doesn't love the aliens, I'm all there. Okay, sure, I would be with them. Are they real, have we been visited by them, and if not, will we? Because, and this is the other follow-up thing, I watched, I'm like an obsessed documentarian
我想谈谈外星人，我爱他们，我想见他们，如果可以的话。没有人不喜欢外星人，我完全支持。好吧，当然，我会和他们在一起。他们是真的吗，我们被他们造访过吗，如果没有，我们会吗？因为，这是另一个后续问题，我看了，我像是一个痴迷的纪录片制作者，
about aliens in space and all that flying, Area 51. So Bob Lazar has this documentary, did you see it? It was about, he claimed he had or has some element that is not of this earth which alien craft is made up of. Is this, do you know this? Yeah, I've heard of these claims, but they don't offer it to laboratories to, I mean, here's the thing, if we're visited by aliens,
关于外星人和太空以及所有那些飞行物，51区。所以鲍勃·拉扎尔有这部纪录片，你看了吗？它是关于，他声称他拥有或曾经拥有某种不属于这个地球的元素，外星飞船就是由它构成的。这是，你知道这个吗？是的，我听说过这些说法，但他们不把这些东西提供给实验室去，我是说，问题是，如果我们被外星人造访过，
why, maybe we've been visited, okay, maybe. I think we have. Okay, let me offer you countervailing thought regarding that. Do you realize we collectively upload a billion photographs and videos to the internet per day? Per day. Every day we upload more photos and videos to the internet that existed in the world in the first hundred years of photography. We have photos of extremely rare phenomena, like buses tumbling and hurricanes or tornadoes.
为什么，也许我们被造访过，好吧，也许。我觉得我们被造访过。好吧，让我为你提供一个相反的观点。你意识到我们每天在互联网上上传十亿张照片和视频吗？每天。我们每天上传到互联网上的照片和视频比摄影术诞生前一百年里世界上存在的还要多。我们有极其罕见现象的照片，比如公共汽车翻滚，还有飓风或龙卷风。
In the day you wouldn't say, oh, that's interesting, let me go home and get my camera and film this. No, everybody's got a camera. Until everybody had a camera, you had all these reports of people getting abducted. Where's the photo of the craft? Why is it that your best evidence for aliens visiting is fuzzy Navy video? Why is that your best evidence? What do you think about the Navy video, Neil? What do you think?
在过去，你不会说，哦，那很有趣，让我回家拿相机拍下来。不，每个人都有相机。直到每个人都有相机之前，你才有所有那些关于人们被绑架的报道。飞船的照片在哪里？为什么你认为外星人造访的最佳证据是模糊的海军视频？为什么那是你最好的证据？你觉得海军视频怎么样，尼尔？你怎么看？
I don't know what it is. That's why it's you, unidentified flying object. But in this documentary, they say, you know, what you're saying, why wouldn't aliens come down and greet us and why don't they sail us? Because, and the explanation is, they are afraid of us. And they're afraid of what we would do to them. So the common denominator of all conspiracy theorists is when they don't have the data,
我不知道那是什么。这就是为什么它是你，不明飞行物。但在这部纪录片里，他们说，你知道，你说的，为什么外星人不下来迎接我们，为什么他们不……因为，解释是，他们害怕我们。他们害怕我们会对他们做什么。所以所有阴谋论者的共同点是，当他们没有数据时，
they have to invent something to bridge the gap in their data. So I'm not bridging any gap. I'm saying everybody is a recorder. Where's the evidence of these visitations? Why is it that crop circles only happen when nobody's looking? All right. Why? Are the aliens just shy? Okay, aliens are shy. Then maybe they don't want to be disturbed by us. Fine, okay?
他们必须编造一些东西来填补他们数据中的空白。所以我没有填补任何空白。我说每个人都是记录者。这些造访的证据在哪里？为什么麦田怪圈只在没人看的时候出现？好吧。为什么？外星人只是害羞吗？好吧，外星人很害羞。那也许他们不想被我们打扰。好吧，没问题？
But when the aliens finally come who are not shy, I don't think they're only gonna show up in fuzzy Navy video. So let's close with this. First of all, we do have one thing in common, you and I. You have over a dozen honorary doctorates because of all the knowledge in your brain, while I have over a dozen doctors
但当那些不害羞的外星人最终到来时，我不认为他们只会出现在模糊的海军视频里。所以让我们以此结束。首先，我们确实有一点共同点，你和我。你拥有十几项荣誉博士学位，因为你大脑里的所有知识，而我有十几位医生
treating the condition of my brain. So what are the scientists getting right right now, and what are they getting wrong as far as COVID and global warming? Okay, so one of the challenges is when you model climate. It's very messy. There's a lot of, there's the heat from the sun, there's the uptake of carbon dioxide in the ocean, there's the spewing of carbon dioxide.
治疗我的大脑状况。那么科学家们现在在新冠和全球变暖方面做对了什么，又做错了什么？好吧，所以挑战之一是当你模拟气候时。它非常混乱。有很多，有来自太阳的热量，有海洋对二氧化碳的吸收，有二氧化碳的排放。
It's very complicated. And so what we need is training on how to think about models presented by scientists. Because every model has an uncertainty range. And so you present the model and the uncertainty range to lawmakers and to policy people and say, here's the best available knowledge. Now find a political solution to this. You don't say, take the politics and say, oh, we deny what your scientists are saying. What is that?
它非常复杂。所以我们需要的是关于如何思考科学家提出的模型的培训。因为每个模型都有一个不确定性范围。所以你把模型和不确定性范围呈现给立法者和政策制定者，说，这是目前最好的可用知识。现在去寻找一个政治解决方案。你不能说，采取政治手段，然后说，哦，我们否认你们科学家所说的。那是什么？
What are you doing? This is a recipe for disaster. As I've said, I tweeted this recently, every disaster movie begins with what? People ignoring the warnings of a scientist. Right, right, right. Of course. But it goes to what you were saying before. As we know, and whether people want to admit it or not, we are constantly driven by geopolitical goals, et cetera, personal... And I accept that, but just don't put those in front of objectively true scientific information.
你在做什么？这是灾难的根源。正如我所说，我最近发推文说，每部灾难电影都是以什么开始的？人们无视科学家的警告。对，对，对。当然。但这回到了你之前所说的。正如我们所知，无论人们是否愿意承认，我们总是受到地缘政治目标等因素的驱动，个人的……我接受这一点，但不要把这些放在客观真实的科学信息之前。
Of course. Because then you're arguing a house of cards, and nothing good will ever come of that. So maybe we need to retrain people to understand what science is, how and why it works, what is an objective truth, what does it mean to be convinced by something? Why do we have people who think Earth is flat?
当然。因为那样你就是在争论空中楼阁，永远不会有任何好结果。所以也许我们需要重新培训人们去理解什么是科学，它是如何以及为什么运作的，什么是客观真理，被某事说服意味着什么？为什么我们会有认为地球是平的人？
Why? What, what? I know it's crazy. Where is the failure? Do you think global warming is the next quote, pandemic that we're gonna be dealing with? Look, it's an existential crisis that's happening on a longer time scale than the pandemic is.
为什么？什么，什么？我知道这很疯狂。失败在哪里？你认为全球变暖是我们要面对的下一个所谓的“大流行”吗？看，这是一场存在主义危机，它发生的时间尺度比大流行要长。
So the timeframes over which things have been happening with regard to the pandemic are rapid. They're happening hourly, all right? And we all need to behave coherently to fight it. It's like saying, oh, well, some states wants to open before other states and my favorite analog to that is that's like opening a peeing section of the pool. Okay?
所以大流行发生的时间框架是迅速的。它们每小时都在发生，好吗？我们都需要协调一致地去对抗它。这就像说，哦，好吧，有些州想比其他州先开放，我最喜欢的类比是，那就像在游泳池里开辟一个撒尿区。好吗？
Okay? Okay? Okay? Yeah, just go to that section of the pool and pee there. Here's the problem. The virus is not visible. Okay? If, by the way, if your pee turned purple
好吗？好吗？好吗？是的，只要去游泳池的那一部分撒尿就行了。问题是，病毒是看不见的。好吗？顺便说一句，如果你的尿液接触到氯气会变成紫色，
in contact with the chlorine, everybody would be called out for that, okay? Right. Instantly, but you can't see the virus. And so people think they're somehow immune to it. But if a monster came out of the woods, grabbed people at the rate that COVID deaths are happening, grabbed them and bit their head off and spilled their bloods in the streets,
每个人都会因此被叫停，好吗？对。立刻，但你看不见病毒。所以人们认为他们以某种方式对它免疫。但如果一个怪物从树林里出来，以新冠死亡发生的速度抓住人们，抓住他们并咬掉他们的头，把他们的血洒在街上，
the coordinated effort in the world to get rid of this creature would know no bounds, okay. So here we have a virus that you can't see and somehow you think is not gonna affect you This is a problem with human cognition and human Again, it's it's relates to the Serengeti. Is it big and it can eat you I'm scared of it Otherwise, I don't know. I'm not scared. Okay, even though if I should be it's amazing the resources and That the government uses and the money and the power to solve this problem almost immediately when they could do that with anything.
世界上消除这种生物的协调努力将是无止境的，好吗。所以我们这里有一种你看不见的病毒，而你却认为它不会影响你。这是人类认知的问题，人类……再一次，它与塞伦盖蒂有关。它大吗，它能吃掉你吗？我害怕它。否则，我不知道。我不害怕。好吧，即使我应该害怕。政府为了解决这个问题几乎立即使用的资源、金钱和权力是惊人的，而他们本可以用这些来做任何事情。
Very good point. And so for me, it was a shot across our bow. Think if hostile aliens came and visited. We should all coordinate. Put down your weapons against each other because they're after humans and we are all human. And it could be the greatest peace Inducing force there ever was for all humans to realize they have a common enemy
很好的观点。所以对我来说，这是一个警告。想想如果有敌对的外星人来访。我们都应该协调一致。放下你们彼此之间的武器，因为他们针对的是人类，而我们都是人类。这可能是人类意识到他们有一个共同敌人所能产生的最伟大的和平推动力。
So my point is this is a practice run global warming is happening on a slower time scale than weeks Yet we all have to coordinate you can't say well if China's not gonna fix the air What why should I when air molecules don't need passports to go from one country to another neither do water molecules and pollution molecules So at some point we have to think globally as one species and I don't see that happening anytime soon You know, we did there was an initial big response to this pandemic and when people were, you know Everybody's locked down all of a sudden nobody know what to do But it's about that sustained interest in it. And it's somebody I remember somebody saying it's such a, we're experiencing such an American lockdown that eventually people are like, I'm kind of bored of it now.
所以我的观点是，这是一次预演。全球变暖发生的时间尺度比几周要慢。然而我们都必须协调。你不能说，好吧，如果中国不修复空气，我为什么要修复？当空气分子不需要护照就能从一个国家去到另一个国家时，水分子和污染分子也不需要。所以到某个时候，我们必须作为一个物种从全球角度思考，而我并没有看到这种情况很快发生。你知道，我们确实做过，对这次大流行有一个初步的大反应，当人们，你知道，每个人都被封锁时，突然没人知道该做什么。但这是关于那种持续的兴趣。我记得有人说，我们正在经历一场如此美国式的封锁，以至于人们最终会觉得，我现在有点厌倦了。
Right. It's not headlines anymore. It's not really. Yeah, it's not really that interesting to me anymore. And the problem is, is that what happens is once again, certain interests, special interests, they start to outweigh the value of this sustained interest in overcoming this. So let me, let me be devil's advocate here for a moment. So you're a restaurant worker and now restaurants are closed by law.
对。它不再是头条新闻了。真的不是。是的，它对我来说真的没那么有趣了。问题在于，再次发生的是，某些利益，特殊利益，它们开始超过克服这一问题的持续兴趣的价值。所以让我，让我在这里唱一下反调。所以你是一名餐馆员工，现在餐馆被法律关闭了。
Okay, you're a busboy, you're a whatever. And so the problem is we didn't go into this with a plan to give people hope and expectations for how they will return to normal. So the governmental handling of the scientific information, you know, in hindsight it's easy to say that it was botched. I don't know how to have done it differently. I don't have a silver bullet here, but I can tell you, the next time this happens, we got to have a rollout plan. And the factory floors, factory, you go into virus mode, and people separate, and the production goes down a little,
好吗，你是个服务员，你是个什么人。所以问题是我们进入这个状态时并没有一个计划来给人们希望和对他们如何恢复正常的期望。所以政府对科学信息的处理，你知道，事后看来很容易说搞砸了。我不知道该怎么做才不同。我这里没有灵丹妙药，但我可以告诉你，下一次发生这种情况时，我们必须有一个推广计划。工厂车间，工厂，你进入病毒模式，人们分开，产量下降一点，
but it doesn't go to zero, okay? And you have people shifts, and people work this eight-hour shift and that eight-hour shift so that they're not right on top of each other. We didn't have any of those plans, and that's what you need. Do you think that we need to get ready for this happening, not necessarily with corona or a different corona or whatever it is, that this is our new reality?
但它不会降到零，好吗？你有轮班，人们工作这个八小时班和那个八小时班，这样他们就不会挤在一起。我们没有任何这些计划，而这就是你所需要的。你认为我们需要为这种情况做好准备吗，不一定是新冠或不同的新冠或其他什么，这就是我们的新现实？
It's called disaster preparedness, and the problem is no one wants to spend money on it if it's not an obvious threat. And let me get back to the CO2 warming the planet. If CO2 were purple, and you'd walk by a car and you saw purple stuff coming out, well purple's too pretty. If it was sludgy brown and you see this coming out
这叫灾难准备，问题是如果它不是一个明显的威胁，没人想在上面花钱。让我回到二氧化碳使地球变暖的问题。如果二氧化碳是紫色的，你走过一辆车，看到紫色的东西出来，嗯，紫色太漂亮了。如果它是泥泞的棕色，你看到这个出来，
and you see it coming out of smoke, and you see that and it just stayed in the air, you would say, we gotta stop this. This is hurting me, this is killing me. But it's invisible and you can't smell it. And so we're very ostrich-like in this regard. Well, Neil, I know you gotta run. I'm a huge fan of science, I'm a huge fan of facts,
你看到它从烟雾中出来，你看到那个，它只是停留在空气中，你会说，我们必须停止这个。这在伤害我，这在杀死我。但它是看不见的，你闻不到它。所以我们在这方面非常像鸵鸟。好吧，尼尔，我知道你得走了。我是科学的忠实粉丝，我是事实的忠实粉丝，
and I'm a huge fan of the good people, and you are all three of those things, so thank you so much for being here today. You've had like three or four fax machines in your life, haven't you? Yeah, for sure. And I still use it, I get like auditions from it, and like your life, haven't you? Yeah, for sure. And I just, I still use it. I get like auditions from it.
我是好人的忠实粉丝，而你这三点都占了，所以非常感谢你今天来到这里。你这辈子用过三四台传真机吧？是的，当然。而且我还在用，我从上面收到试镜，就像你的生活一样，对吧？是的，当然。而且我只是，我还在用。我从上面收到试镜。
It's good for you, Sean. I've got to refill it, actually. But Neil, thank you so much. Yeah, please keep sharing your knowledge in the generous and interesting way that you do. Well, thanks for that. And I'd love to come back on. I mean, when you...
这对你有好处，肖恩。我得去补充一下，其实。但尼尔，非常感谢。是的，请继续以你那种慷慨和有趣的方式分享你的知识。好吧，谢谢。我很乐意再来。我是说，当你……
Oh, we'd love that. If all your other guests say, no, I'm never doing that again, you can call me back. Listen, I was gonna say I can't speak for the other guys, but I can. I would say, I know that we would all be delighted to have a part two with you. Yes, for sure. If you'd be willing to do it.
哦，我们很乐意。如果所有其他嘉宾都说，不，我再也不做那个了，你可以再叫我。听着，我本来想说我不能代表其他人，但我可以。我会说，我知道我们都会很高兴和你进行第二部分。是的，当然。如果你愿意的话。
Because the universe is vast. And I also wanna say, if I could spend just one moment fanboying, you guys make really fun movies, and they're just, for me, it's a little bit of escapism in it. Movie. Yeah. Movie.
因为宇宙是浩瀚的。我还想说，如果我能花一点时间当个粉丝，你们拍的电影真的很有趣，对我来说，这是一种逃避现实。电影。是的。电影。
Oh, thank you. So just keep it going. We need it. We need the diversion. The levity. Yeah, the levity. Oh, thanks, pal. Which would be the opposite of gravity.
哦，谢谢。所以继续保持。我们需要它。我们需要这种消遣。轻松感。是的，轻松感。哦，谢谢，伙计。那将是重力的反面。
Levity. Gravity. Ooh. Way to bring it back around. Beautiful. Right there. Well, thank you very much, Neil. Thanks, Neil you very much, Neil. Thank you very, very much. We'll see you later.
轻松感。重力。噢。真会绕回来。太美了。就在那儿。好吧，非常感谢你，尼尔。谢谢，尼尔，非常感谢你。谢谢，非常非常感谢。回头见。
Bye. Isn't he, like, for me, I don't know why I have that chip in my brain that is endlessly fascinated by that stuff. I could talk for hours and hours and hours about all of those topics. Same here, I'm incredibly, the one thing I wanted to ask him him and I could ask you guys the same
再见。他是不是，对我来说，我不知道为什么我大脑里有那个芯片，对那些东西有着无尽的迷恋。我可以花几个小时几个小时地谈论所有这些话题。我也是，我非常，我唯一想问他的一件事，我也可以问你们同样的问题，
because I don't know what my answer would be about it either. Do you think if you went up to space and then you came back down, if you just did like one lap and you came, would you be like- Exhausted? Depressed? Oh. Just literally to get up so high to like look back down at the earth, then come back down, everything will be so anticlimactic.
因为我也不知道我的答案会是什么。你认为如果你去了太空然后回来，如果你只是绕了一圈然后你回来，你会像……精疲力竭？沮丧？噢。仅仅是为了飞得那么高去回望地球，然后回来，一切都会变得如此虎头蛇尾。
I wonder if it would be. I think more people need to think like that. Like you're saying, Jason, well, any astronaut I've heard in an interview or anything, they say the exact same thing you're saying. You go up there, you get a picture and an image of the world we live in and you realize how small it is. And every astronaut that has experienced that has said,
我想知道会不会。我认为更多的人需要那样思考。就像你说的，杰森，好吧，我听过的任何宇航员在采访中或任何地方，他们说的和你说的完全一样。你飞到那里，你得到了一张我们居住的世界的照片和图像，你意识到它是多么渺小。而且每个经历过那一切的宇航员都说，
you realize that we're all the same and that why can't we figure out how to get along? You know what I mean? And I think every astronaut always has asked like, what is that experience when you're out in space and they say it's out of this world? Nice one. Well, you just dropped out for a little bit.
你意识到我们都是一样的，为什么我们不能弄清楚如何相处？你知道我的意思吗？而且我认为每个宇航员总是被问到，当你在太空中时那种体验是什么，他们说那是超凡脱俗的。说得好。好吧，你刚才掉线了一会儿。
Sorry, what happened? There you are, you're back. Trust me it was pretty good Sean. Well did you guys learn anything today? So much. How badly do we need to have him? He should be, we should have him on like once every three months just to keep us, you know, what's going on with the Cosmo, what's happening? Right, right? When Neil said, every single day we upload over a billion photos, Will goes, I mean, the four of us. He loves to post. Will's a real poster. I know.
抱歉，发生了什么？你回来了，你回来了。相信我，这很棒，肖恩。好吧，你们今天学到什么了吗？太多了。我们有多需要他？他应该，我们应该每三个月请他来一次，只是为了让我们，你知道，了解宇宙发生了什么，发生了什么？对吧，对吧？当尼尔说，我们每天上传超过十亿张照片时，威尔说，我是说，我们四个。他喜欢发帖。威尔是个真正的发帖狂。我知道。
Tag it, post it, like it. Will, do you tweet still? Rarely. Yeah, he does. Will's very frequent. It's like, hey, lines are long at Starbys today. It's like, he does. Will's with a very frequent, it's like, hey lines are long at Starbys today. Shut up, Will. It's my right to call it Starbys. I wanted to ask Neil if he starts his day off at Starbucks. Wow. Wow. He probably pays with Starbucks. Do you guys
标记它，发布它，点赞它。威尔，你还发推文吗？很少。是的，他发。威尔非常频繁。就像，嘿，今天星巴克排队很长。就像，他发。威尔非常频繁，就像，嘿，今天星巴克排队很长。闭嘴，威尔。我有权叫它星巴克。我想问尼尔他是否以星巴克开始他的一天。哇。哇。他可能用星巴克支付。你们
get that? Do you guys get that? Yeah, no, I got it. Sean, do you get your own joke? Do you even get your own joke? All right, let's let our listener get to dinner or whatever. Okay. I love the idea that all our, anybody who listens to our podcast is going, is rushing to a meal. We have to book our sole listener at some point. That's what I'm saying, that's what I'm saying. Thank you, Sean.
听懂了吗？你们听懂了吗？是的，不，我听懂了。肖恩，你听懂你自己的笑话了吗？你甚至听懂你自己的笑话了吗？好吧，让我们让我们的听众去吃晚饭或什么的。好吧。我喜欢这个想法，我们所有的，任何听我们播客的人都在赶去吃饭。我们必须在某个时候预订我们唯一的听众。这就是我说的，这就是我说的。谢谢，肖恩。
All right. Love you guys. Love you guys. Love you too. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart.
好吧。爱你们。爱你们。也爱你们。再见。再见。再见。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。聪明。少。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。